SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE:
Welcome to Cloud OnAir,
Google Cloud's live
webinar series.
We're hosting live webinars
every Tuesday this February.
I am Saptarshi Mukherjee.
I lead Product Marketing
for Data Analytics.
And we are joined
by Eric Schmidt.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Hi.
I'm Eric Schmidt.
I'm a Developer Advocate in
the Google Cloud Platform team.
And I spend most of my time on
data analytics and data science
workflows.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE: Great.
And we're going to
talk about love.
What's a better day than the
day before Valentine's Day
talking about love?
ERIC SCHMIDT: Especially
if you are in love.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE: Yeah.
And this topic is
about human emotions,
and how do you understand
human emotions,
apply algebra to
determine human emotions.
And we're going to talk
about research work
by Dr. Robert Plutchik
in this field.
But we're going to
talk about how do we
apply emotion
arithmetic in business
and make it real to
delight our customers?
In that context,
we're going to talk
about Google Cloud's Data
Analytics and Data Science
Platform.
And then we're going
to do a real demo.
We're going to do
real coding, Eric?
ERIC SCHMIDT: We are, yes.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE:
OK, that's great.
Let's hope it all goes well.
With that, let's
talk, about love.
Love has been one of
the most argued topics
that I can ever remember.
And I think that's true
for many, many decades
and centuries.
We have great poets
who have defined loves.
We have great philosophers,
and most recently
evolutionary biologists,
talking about love
as the evolutionary necessity.
So it's an interesting topic,
top of mind for many people.
And we have been discussing this
in the context of philosophy,
poet, psychology.
And we're going to define "love"
is equal to trust plus joy.
And how do we come
to this equation?
So that's the fun.
Let's get started.
The psychologists
have been trying
to understand love and
human emotions for decades.
And one of the most
cited work in this space
is from Dr. Robert
Plutchik, who came up
with this very interesting
model of human psychology called
the "Wheel of Emotion."
And what it does, it allows us
to come with resultant emotion
based on underneath
nuanced emotions.
So for example,
as for his model,
love equals to
trust plus joy, awe
equals to fear plus
amazement, and then we
have contempt, which
is anger plus disgust.
But let's look at the model.
The way to interpret
this model is
you have an ordinal
listing of human emotions
throughout this model.
And the emotions which are
at the very central piece
of this model are the
most intense ones.
If you see admiration,
terror, amazement, grief,
these are very intense
human emotions.
And as you try to move outside
of the wheel across the petals,
the intensity of those
emotions come down.
And if you add the two emotions
in the adjacent petals,
you get the resultant emotion
in between the petals.
So for example, if we zoom
into this particular aspect
of the wheel, joy plus
trust is equal to love.
And similarly, if
we see awe, it's
a state of fear and amazement.
And when we got
to know that we're
going to talk about
psychology in a live webinar,
it give me a bit of
a terror, but then we
got to know we have a lot
of people listening to us.
That's a huge
piece of amazement.
So we are in the state
of awe, pretty much.
With that, let's talk
about what does it all mean
for you, for your businesses.
So this is emotional arithmetic.
And it's extremely
important to understand
that today's customer
feedbacks about product,
about experiences, are
getting really nuanced.
It's not just OK to understand
the sentiment of a customer's
dialect or a customer's
written piece of text.
We need to understand what
the customer is actually
trying to convey.
And that's when
we're going to get
the juice of that comment
or the talk track,
and be able to offer
them something really,
really interesting.
Let's look at a real sample.
So this is from our demo that
we're going to do later today.
This is a product
review from one
of our customers,
who's talking about one
of the beauty products
that the person has bought
from the e-commerce site.
And the person talks about
that the product was great.
The person got a
free sample of it.
The experience was great.
But then the pricing was not as
per the customer expectation.
And at the very end,
the person is hopeful.
And hopefully, the company is
going to correct the pricing
and make it a really good
deal for the customer.
ERIC SCHMIDT: And this
one feels like they're
polar opposites, right?
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE: Exactly.
So if we just do a
simple sentiment analysis
on this piece of
text, you will see
there are a bunch of positive
sentiments flowing in.
The product is great and the
company has done a great job.
And then we have a bunch
of negative sentiments
that are going in.
So the simple sentiment
analysis is not
going to give us great details.
But if you go and apply
our emotional wheel,
the Wheel of
Emotions, you will see
that are nuanced emotions
playing throughout the text.
There is a level
of anticipation.
There's a level of joy and
trust, like this is great.
I found the sample to
be working really well.
And then there are levels
of negative emotions
throughout the text, like
the pricing was not right.
There was a level of
anger and disgust.
So if we apply the
Wheel of Emotion model
here to understand how we
can delight this customer,
if you see the person
has anticipation and joy.
And if I merge these
two, I see a lot of hope.
And there is a level
of anticipation
that the customer has.
And correcting the price
may convert this customer
into a great ambassador
for the product.
So with that, let's talk about
real-life examples of where
we can apply the
emotional arithmetic,
and understand emotion,
analyze the online retail.
We're going to show the demo and
talk about how we apply there.
But for example, gaming
analytics-- a lot of companies
are providing gaming titles.
The gamers are all the time very
vocal about their experience
with these games.
And if we can understand
their emotions,
we'll be able to offer them
more personalized gaming
experiences.
And marketing overall
is trying to be
more relevant to the
intended audience.
So it has huge application
in the field of marketing
analytics, try to making
sure that the campaigns
and the content are as
for the audience's needs.
Now, if you try to analyze
customer's emotions
in real time, and they're
coming from millions
of your customers, you
can't do it manually.
ERIC SCHMIDT: No.
Your example is great.
You showed us one,
but how do we do
this with millions and
millions of comments
over millions of customers?
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE:
Yeah, and then
it pretty much becomes a big
data problem for all of us.
Here is what Google Cloud has
to offer in the data analytics
space.
And we make it really simple for
our customers, because our data
analytics platform
is serverless.
So what it means is
basically, for you
to build a emotional analytics
model, apply machine learning,
understand human
emotions, and then apply
our learning into a
product personalization,
you can do this
pretty much end to end
without thinking about any
infrastructure, capacity
planning, load balancing--
nothing of that sort.
Because anything else,
those infrastructural needs
are taken care of
by the platform.
And as an analyst,
you can just simply
focus on doing data analytics.
And we're going to talk
about all of these tools
in the context of the demo.
Now, the first thing in
the data analytics stack
is the data management
platform, where
you store all your
customer feedbacks,
the emotions in real
time as they come in.
And our offering in this
space is Google BigQuery.
BigQuery is different.
It is a data warehouse.
It's an enterprise
data warehouse.
But it was designed
for an ML-first world.
If you look at the
evolution of data warehouses
over the course of
the last many years,
data warehouses were
initially designed
for a BI-first,
reporting-first batch paradigm.
And now, as companies
are increasingly
investing in science
workflows and building machine
learning models from their
most important data sets,
the data warehouses need to
live up to that expectation.
And that's what
exactly BigQuery does.
So the first thing is,
BigQuery is massively scalable.
So whether you analyze
your customer feedback
from a few hundred customers
or millions of customers,
the same system is going to
support your analysis needs.
It is very simple to use.
It supports ANSI SQL.
You can write queries in the
language that you already know.
And it supports
real-time data analysis.
Like data warehouse,
we typically
relate to the batch paradigm,
but BigQuery supports
real-time streaming inserts.
And we're going to show
that, how it works.
And it's encrypted, durable.
It kind of checks
all the boxes that
are needed in a modern
data warehouse system.
So with that, it's
almost time for the code.
Let's make it real.
ERIC SCHMIDT:
Great, thanks, Sap.
And I want to say, hey,
Happy Valentine's Day.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE:
Thank you very much.
Happy Valentine's Day, everyone.
ERIC SCHMIDT: All right,
so as we get into the demo,
we need to do some
pre-work, because you just
can't go build an online
site or a data warehouse,
unless you go and get
data, and you ingest data,
and start doing some analysis.
So the first thing that
I want to talk about
is, if you wanted
to go do analysis,
say emotional analysis
over comments and orders,
et cetera, you're going
to have to go get data
from various systems-- your CRM
system, billing, point of sale,
et cetera.
And you may use a myriad
of different tools.
So we work with
lots of companies.
And the average
rate right now is
that most companies use
around 30 different tools
to do ingestion, transformation,
analysis, et cetera.
If your goal is to get a
holistic view of customers,
you end up having
to use lots of tools
over lots of different systems.
One of the tools that
we used for this demo
is Google Cloud Dataflow.
What Dataflow enables you
to do is to point a job,
a graph of instructions
at some data source,
read from that source, provide
a set of transformations.
Maybe you want to
read user comments,
and you want to parse
out all the words,
or you want to load
your line items
and join that to some
catalog information.
It doesn't really matter.
You just go ahead and
point it at the source,
run your transformations,
and then load your data
to some destination
like BigQuery.
The key here is that this
is completely serverless.
And it is optimized for
embarrassingly parallelized
operations, say like reading
100 million user comments
and then loading
them into BigQuery.
So I use Dataflow as my Step
One to go ahead and read data
from all of my sources.
With this, I was able
to then quickly get
some high-level views of the
data using Data Studio, which
is a serverless product.
It's free, as well,
that you can use
to build real-time,
interactive dashboard.
So this dashboard is on
top of the demo, called
"You Look Marvelous."
We're going to show you
that here in a minute.
This view is showing me some
high-level sales information--
demographics, where are
my sales coming from,
what's the difference
between, say, online sales
and in-store sales.
Here's another view
that we quickly
built, which is how do
products purchase affinitize?
So if people are
buying product A
and they also buy a product
B, what's the likelihood
that they would also
buy a product C,
so I could build a
simple recommendation
based on basket analysis.
So I was quickly able
to go from, say, no data
to ingesting data to
quickly visualizing it.
And for this demo,
what I want to do
is kind of flip the analysis.
Instead of focusing on just the
customer view, or the product
in terms of the
sales aspect of it,
I want to understand why
did they buy a product.
Was it effective?
Would they buy it again?
Because ultimately,
the more I can
learn about the user's
behavior around the journey
that they took to buy
a particular product,
I could potentially influence a
new purchase, a new user that's
coming to my site.
So how do things work today?
So Sap, you showed that example
of reading one user comment.
And this is what we're going
to show you in the demo.
How things work today is
you usually go into a site.
You would type in a
free search, or maybe
look at the taxonomy
of that site.
You're trying to find a product.
So maybe I'm trying to find
some cream for an acne problem.
And I'm going to get a
bunch of search results
that are ranked on
that site, typically
by most popular, by
price, et cetera.
And I start looking
at the ratings.
And then I look at comments.
And I keep doing this
process over and over again.
And it might take
me 25, 30 minutes
for me to decide whether or not
I'm going to buy this product.
Now, let's play a game.
Sap, you showed that one
that you previously scored.
But in this case,
we don't have any
of the dramatic struggle, the
two-time skin, definitely,
et cetera, et cetera.
This is where us,
as humans, we end up
spending our time and also
emotional energy to figure out,
is this comment a
good comment for me,
in order to make a
purchasing decision?
So what if we showed
you the results
on that site that were ranked
by sentiment and effectiveness
versus top selling?
We can potentially
show you products
that are more appropriate
for you higher in the rank.
And then what if we showed you
comments once you were looking
at a product that were more
appropriate for the product
that you were looking at?
So we could
ultimately shrink down
the overall kind
of purchase time,
and we could also provide
a more effective cycle
to influence the best
possible purchase.
So now that we
understand the context,
let's get into the demo.
The first thing I want to show
you is our "You Look Marvelous"
site.
This is a fake demo
built with fake products,
but these products actually
exist in the real world.
I just anonymised all of them.
So here, I'm going to
go ahead and search
for skincare, and treatments,
and blemish, and acne.
So I'm going to go
ahead and do a search.
And you'll see that the sort
order up here is called my
You Look Marvelous score.
Now typically,
this may be sorted
by price or social popularity.
But now, I have this You
Look Marvelous score.
And you can see right here, this
product, the sale [INAUDIBLE]
still max treatment has a
47% You Look Marvelous score.
Now take a step
back, and oh, 47%--
that sounds low.
But it's the
second-ranked top product.
So if I go ahead and
I click into this,
it's going to go out and
retrieve all the product
information for that particular
product, pull it back.
Here's the product.
This is what it
says it's good for.
And I'll start
scrolling down, and you
can see that this product has
an overall rating of 4.24.
That sounds pretty good.
It's got 105 five-star ratings.
And you can kind of
see the distribution
of the other ratings.
So right here, if you were
just looking at ratings,
you'd probably be influenced.
Hey, this feels pretty good.
This may be a good
product for me.
But what we've also
done on the You
Look Marvelous site is we've
taken all of the underlying
comment information, and ran it
through our emotional analysis
workflow that Sap
was talking about.
And now you can see the
distribution of emotions.
So you can start
making decisions.
Well, there's a lot of
positivity around this.
A lot of people loved it.
A lot of people are--
say 3% are showing anticipation.
But there's also a decent
amount of negativity.
And in the real world,
nothing's going to be perfect.
You're always going
to have products
that have some type
of distribution
between positive and negative,
and then various aspects
of emotional rating.
And the last thing to show
you here is the comments.
So these first
three comments-- we
selected them based on
some psychological knobs
that we built to determine what
comments are the most positive,
and are also the most
information dense.
So as a potential
purchaser, this
is where we spend a lot of time.
We're reading those comments,
trying to figure out,
is this the best comment for me?
What happens if you
didn't have to do that?
On the You Look Marvelous
site, you don't.
These comments are the comments
that are the most appropriate
from an emotional aspect related
to the products' reported
goals.
As well as the comments that
have the most information
density inside of them.
So kind of keep that in mind.
So this is kind of how we built
this You Look Marvelous score,
and how we tried to improve the
overall shopping experience.
Let's look at how we did that.
So I talked a little bit about
getting data into BigQuery
using Google Cloud Dataflow.
I'm going to go ahead
and run this query.
You can see these are all my
tables over here in my You
Look Marvelous data warehouse.
So I have comments, line items,
locations, orders, et cetera.
And this query that
I'm writing right now
is looking at a few
gigs worth of data.
So it took just
under 15 seconds,
and I scanned one and
a half gigs of data.
What this query did was,
it's a relatively big query--
no pun intended.
I'm taking all of my orders,
joining them to all the line
items, and then all the line
items to all the product
information, and
then all the comments
for all those products,
so three different
joins across millions
and millions of rows.
And I'm trying to calculate
the top 100 selling
products based on sales, which
is something people normally
think about.
Hey, what are my top
100 selling products?
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE:
Are you making money?
ERIC SCHMIDT: Am I making money?
Yeah, what products
are making money?
But what I wanted
to know was, I want
to rank those top
100 products also
based on the average word
count in the comments.
So I have millions and
millions of comments.
I want to know the average word
count for my top 100 selling
products.
So you can see the product
ID starting with 417
has an average
word count of 688.
And then if I look at my
last product in the list,
starting with 523, it has an
average word count of 182.
So it's a pretty big spread.
And you'll see why this
is important in a minute.
The point here is, once you
have your data into BigQuery,
you can express any type
of query that you want.
And you don't have to worry
about indexing, partitioning,
et cetera.
You literally load data,
write query, period.
So now that I've showed
you how to build a BigQuery
inside of BigQuery, let's
go through a data analysis
and data science
journey to build
that You Look Marvelous score.
I'm going to flip over to
another serverless product.
This is Google Cloud Datalab.
It is, in essence, an
optimized IPython environment
that helps you interact
with Google Cloud resources
as well as any other resource
that you would use inside
of IPython.
So here, this
notebook is focused
on building that You
Look Marvelous score.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE: So are
you going to do that emotion
arithmetic here?
ERIC SCHMIDT: Yes.
We're going to go from
basically raw product view
down to what is that score?
And how do you figure out
what comments to filter?
The first thing to look
at inside of Datalab
is we have these
magic functions.
You see this SQL and
then module products.
Here, I'm defining
a simple query.
And whenever I
run this query, it
will go out, push down
the query to BigQuery,
and return those results.
And I can easily
take SQL Results
and convert them into pandas
DataFrames, which is the area
that I'm more comfortable with.
I love SQL.
I love writing queries inside
of Big Query, et cetera.
I want to get this data
inside of pandas DataFrames
so I can quickly do
things like basic
looking at descriptive
analysis on top of the data.
So I went out.
I queried all of my products.
And I want to look at their
average star rating, the thing
that we were influenced before.
So here is all the
products in my catalog.
And you see things that are
tightly clustered in the--
at the 50th percentile,
we're about 4.2,
70th percentile about 4.4.
Now, whenever I was doing the
analysis-- and by the way,
this data is real--
this struck me.
I was, like, oh, I sell products
that people like overall.
You see it's very, very
tightly distributed.
If I didn't care about the
products that I was selling,
you'd probably see
some outliers you know
further down in the ratings.
As a customer, if
I was using ratings
as a mechanism to disambiguate
one product from another,
this is it.
You're headed down a bad path.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE:
There's too many choices.
ERIC SCHMIDT: There's
too many choices, right.
They all look the same.
So the next thing I did was I
took all of my user comments
for those products, and I ran
them through the Google Cloud
Natural Language API.
And I'll flip over
to that real quickly.
Here's the product page.
And you can go ahead and
test this with any comments
that you want.
I pasted in a comment
and I hit Analyze.
And you can see that the
Google Cloud Natural Language
API will provide you sentiment
at the document level
as well as at the
sentiment level.
So you can see that distribution
that Sap was talking about
before.
It also picks out the entities,
like this a skin cream.
Here is the sentiment
against that entity.
And it also provides
you the syntax tree,
so if you wanted to do some
brute-force lexical processing
on this, you could
say, hey, I want
to look at the top
number of verbs,
or I want to look
at noun phrases,
or I want to look at the
relationships of one syntax
element from another.
So you get all of this
information back from the Cloud
Natural Language API.
And I can use Dataflow to inject
them into my data warehouse.
So now, instead of just
looking at scores, ratings,
I'm now looking at sentiment, so
I run a slightly bigger query.
And this is what the
distribution of sentiment
looks like for those products.
And again, whenever I was doing
this, I was, like, oh, well,
in this case, humans are
doing the right things.
So I know I have
very tight clustering
that's in the positive
range, so around, say,
everything's 50th percentile is
around 0.9 or 1, which is good.
Overall, there is strong
positive sentiment
for the products
that I'm selling.
So if we go ahead
and pivot this,
if you were the owner
of this company,
you're, like, hey, this graph
makes me feel good-- three,
four, five stars
up until the right.
I don't sell any garbage.
I don't have any star
ratings in one and two.
But as a customer, you're not
buying the entire catalog.
You're trying to
buy one product.
So that product that
I just showed you,
on the You Look Marvelous site,
is this product right here.
So how do you start to
disambiguate between, say,
three, four, and
five-star ratings
that the averages in
standard deviation,
especially between four
and five-star ratings--
they're almost the same.
So again, this data
isn't really going
to help you as a customer.
So the next thing I did
is, I needed more data.
And I went and I used an open
source library called Sirocco
that helps you calculate scores
for the Wheel of Emotions
that Sap was talking about.
So I ran all of my
comments through Sirocco,
and now I have a much
wider data set to look at.
In essence, I can
write a bigger query.
You see, now I am selecting
all these emotions.
And I'm going to go ahead
and use a slightly different
visual technique.
Here, I just have
a heat map, where
I have the ratings
on the vertical,
and I have the emotions
on the horizontal.
And what you see here,
your eye kind of naturally
gravitates towards
up and to the right.
Here's where the
most kind of density
is around those raw scores.
So I see a lot of joy,
acceptance, surprise.
This is good.
This is what you'd expect.
But as I start looking left,
I'm, like, wait a minute.
Why is there fear and
some sadness showing up
in this product, even though--
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE:
It was highly rated.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Yeah,
it was highly rated.
And whenever I did this
journey, I was, like, ha ha.
I can go dumpster dive
on even more data,
but I had to take a step
back, saying, well, I'm
trying to build a better ranking
system for these products.
Now, I did do that analysis.
So yes, people were
fearful that they're not
going to be able to
afford the product.
Because they got the
product as a sample.
So they got it from
a friend as a sample.
It was free.
And then it's working for them.
But now they're fearful that
they may not be able to buy it.
Or they're saddened because
the product doesn't necessarily
provide--
the packaging doesn't
provide the ability
to get all the
product out of it.
There are all types
of reasons why
the emotion would pop up here.
Now, with this
information, I now
have the basis to start
building a better sort order
for my comments and products.
Just for the heck of it,
I ran a much bigger query.
So this is Sirocco, the emotion
analysis across all products,
across all comments.
So you can see overall, up
in the top right quadrant,
people like my products.
But there's a lot of fear,
and guilt, and sadness, et
cetera, that I may want to go
dispatch, to see my product
quality folks, say,
hey, go figure out
what's going on here.
Now, once I had this data, I
went back to the customers.
Because we actually did
this with the customers
we were working with.
I was, like, what
would you want to show?
If you knew the emotional
makeup of these comments,
what would you want to show?
And they said, we want to
show customers comments that
are the most objective, in
essence, the most information
dense related to the product.
So we did some research.
And it turns out there's
an inverse relationship
between objectivity and emotion.
So I tried to prove that.
So I went and wrote a fairly
complex query in BigQuery.
So I'm basically pushing
down this analysis.
And what I wanted to
do was find the top two
comments per star rating
that were the most emotional.
So here's the answer to that.
I love, love, love.
I can't keep going on how
much I love this product.
I love this gel, et
cetera, et cetera.
This is a highly
emotional comment.
And you start reading
it, and you're not really
getting any objective
information about the product.
And you can see how
verbose these are.
In essence, a lot of
these are a waste of time
if you're going to show
them to the end user.
So we proved that.
And then if we want
to get to objectivity,
what would this look like if
I pulled out all the emotion?
So I basically take that
same query and I reverse it.
Now, these are the
most objective comments
in five, four, threes, two, one.
So "I can't say enough about how
much I love this black line,"
or "hydrates without
a greasy feeling,
absorbs in the skin quickly,
and is lightweight."
This is a great comment.
It's information rich, and
it talks to the properties
of the product.
So with this, I now have a
way to go ahead and start
determining what
comments I want to show
for a particular product.
And the idea here
was, whenever we're
working with our
customers, they said, well,
we just don't want to show
all positive comments.
The first one we show is
going to be the most positive
and the most objective.
The second one
would be slightly--
it would be the most positive
with a little bit of emotion,
so you have a sense of yeah,
this isn't just a robot
talking about something.
And then if I want to
show negative emotion,
I want to show emotion around
things that I can control.
I can't control if people
are angry about packaging,
because I don't
control the packaging.
But I could help them
if their emotion, say,
were coming from fear,
maybe about pricing
or something like that.
So once you have
that data, you can
start playing with the knobs
in terms of what you actually
want to show.
So now we have this score.
We have this basis score.
And you can use-- you can
weight it however you want.
But we didn't stop there.
The next thing that we
wanted to look at was,
could we determine some
additional information
about a commenter, as
well as a user on a site,
to potentially match
them with comments
that were more appropriate
for them demographically?
So the question would be,
what could we look at?
What cities did they
register from, et cetera?
What types of
products did we buy?
What we wanted to
look at was age range.
So in the cosmetics space,
cosmetics across age
ranges, they behave differently.
And people talk about
them differently.
And in our data set,
we had 20% of our users
who had self-identified into
an age range, basically 18
to 26, 27 to 35, et cetera.
So the question was,
could we analyze
that data to see if there
was a difference between
how, say, a baby boomer
communicates versus how
a millennial communicates?
And if you could see
those differences,
then we could build
a second knob to say,
well, we only want to show
baby boomers comments from baby
boomers, and we only want
to show millennials comments
from millennials.
So how do we do that?
I'm going to flip over to
another Datalab notebook.
This is the notebook that we
built to do age classification.
So using very
similar techniques,
I started my journey by
pulling in a raw data set
from BigQuery, in essence, all
the comments and the buckets
that users were in.
So I only had 20% of my
users had classified age
or had talked about age.
So I'm trying to basically
project and classify
to the 80% of population.
Here, I'm using Keras sitting
on top of TensorFlow as well
as BigQuery.
And I'm going to go
ahead and move down
to the bulk of the
model that I built.
The idea here is that
for every comment,
I have N number of words, and
I'm using an embedding model.
I'm basically saying
for the first 100 words
in that comment, I want to
identify the most closest words
to them.
So it's a technique
called embedding.
So Sap, if you use the word,
"like" and I use the word,
"love," those words
are fairly close.
If you use the word, "hot"
and I use the word, "cold,"
those words are
fairly far apart.
So the idea here is that
if we can cluster comments
based on the distance
between those words,
we could start
seeing, yeah, there's
a difference between
how millennials
and boomers communicate.
So I go ahead and I
run my training data
to train this model.
And there are some interesting
things that pop out of it.
You can see here
that I'm going ahead,
and I'm calling out
to BigQuery, and I
pulled back 21,000 comments.
So I'm going to train
on 16,000 of them.
I try to distribute the
groups between Group 1
and Group 2,
millennials and boomers.
I try to keep the
distribution even so I'm not
creating some type of bias.
And for those
16,000-some comments,
it found 14,302 unique
words, which is good.
This is how I'm going
to create my embeddings.
One of the problems I ran into
is that humans, unfortunately,
don't spell correctly
100% of the time.
So out of the 14,000
words, 3,200 of these words
had null embeddings,
so that people
spelled "moisturizer"
incorrectly, or "breakout,"
et cetera.
So basically, I've kind of
taken the fidelity of the data
that I had.
I have higher fidelity, but
I have less data to analyze.
So I was kind of
concerned at this point.
I'm like, oh, no,
humans can't spell.
That's OK.
I kept going.
I kept training.
And with the data, even with
the quality issues I had,
within 62%, I can accurately
predict whether or not
you're a millennial or a boomer.
So here's a good example.
So my predicted label was
1, which is a millennial.
The actual label is 1.
This says, "I'm a
teenager, so I just
started breaking out after I
washed my face, et cetera."
Now in this case, "teenager"
is a really, really good hint.
If you see, "I'm a
teenager," "teen," et cetera,
you know the clustering is going
to be way, way more efficient.
This one, boomer to boomer,
you kind of read it,
and you're, like, well,
obviously, there's
some type of
information, some type
of pattern within that text that
classified them as a boomer.
And the great part is
that you don't necessarily
have to go and
decompose why it is.
You just know that you
accurately predicted.
And I think with some
more tuning techniques,
and cleaning up these
bad embeddings up here,
I could probably get this to
about 70%, which is awesome.
So now I have the
ability to tune a knob
and say whether or not you're
a millennial or a boomer.
And I also have knobs
to tune whether or not
you want to see emotional
or non-emotional, objective
or non-objective comments.
So using those two techniques,
if you come back to the site,
those two techniques
are ultimately
what is driving what is
rendered on this site.
On the back end, what we
don't show in this demo,
there's another
seminar that has been
done on the-- it's called "The
Marketing Analytics Starter
Pack."
It's showing you how to test
whether or not what you built
is effective using
Google Analytics.
So you can imagine if a
user read these two comments
or clicked on them
and made a purchasing
decision, through Google
Analytics I could track all
that click stream, do
some basic A/B testing,
and say yes, this model that
we can came up with this way
is the most effective
one to drive sales.
All right, let's get back
into the slides, and wrap up.
Real quick note-- so
the Sirocco library
that I used is Java based.
You can go out.
It's open source.
You can find it in GitHub.
And it talks about how you
can use various indexing
techniques, and how you can
leverage it with Dataflow.
But you don't have to
use it with Dataflow.
If you're running this inside of
Apache Spark or something else,
or maybe you could use
it-- you would even
want to run it locally
on your own machine,
although that wouldn't be
great for a big data problem.
So I encourage you to go
out and look at Sirocco
if you're trying to look
at the emotion analysis.
If you just need sentiment
information and/or
the lexical graph, go ahead
and use Cloud Natural Language
Processing.
It is a great
technique if you need
that higher-level information.
So what did we show you?
The journey was go ahead and
ingest, fire up BigQuery.
It's super simple.
You basically say
"Create data sets,
go ahead and load tables."
And you can either do that
in batch or streaming mode.
BigQuery enables you
to ingest the data
in real time, up to 100,000
records per second per table.
And then go ahead and
do some quick analysis
inside of Datalab or
inside of Data Studio.
We talked about doing
some enrichments.
So you could use the Cloud
Natural Language API.
You could also use
our Vision API.
You could do any type
of enrichment technique
that you want using Dataflow
or another ETL tool.
And then we get into
the analysis piece.
So you could do something like
with Sirocco, you could write
your own analysis algorithms.
And then once you get
into feature development
and modeling, you can do
that inside of a Datalab.
You can do inside of IPython.
You can do it inside of
R. It doesn't matter,
to go ahead and create
the types of features
that you want in order
to build a model.
And then finally, if you need
to go ahead and train and serve
this at scale, you can go ahead
and use Cloud Machine Learning
Engine.
So we went through a bunch.
But this is, in essence, how we
got back to this architecture.
But now this has
been contextualized
in a retail scenario.
But this would work in
any type of scenario.
This could be for life sciences.
It could be for
financial services.
It could be for doing
analysis over sports.
So with that, Sap, I want
to thank you for your time.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE: Absolutely.
ERIC SCHMIDT: We've kind of
gone from zero to emotions.
And we understand
how to quantify love.
And with that, we're going to
flip over to the live Q and A.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE: So Eric,
we talked about e-commerce.
And in real businesses, you
will have hundreds of thousands
of customers leaving
comments on your site,
and expressing their
emotions and sentiments.
How can I use Cloud Natural
Language API to score
lots and lots of comments?
ERIC SCHMIDT: Sure.
So there are several techniques.
The one that we talked
about was ultimately,
you want to do this in the
most parallelized fashion as
possible.
Because you have lots of things,
and if you did them serially,
it would take you lots of time.
So using a product like Cloud
Dataflow or another ETL tool.
So maybe you wanted to use Spark
or just a straight MapReduce
job.
You could go ahead and
build a graph that will then
go ahead and
parallelize the analysis
of each one of those comments.
And that's the
technique that we used.
Here we just used
the cloud NLP API,
and then build a function
that says, OK, input comment,
call function, and then
you parallelize that.
So you could effectively do
a job that would, say, take
24 hours in total.
You could run that job in
six minutes of clock time.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE: Great.
And what if I need
to do something
more custom than what Cloud
Natural language API offers?
ERIC SCHMIDT: Yeah,
good question.
So Cloud NLP, as
we showed you, you
can get document and
sentence-level sentiments.
You can also understand
the syntax tree.
If you need more,
there are a bunch
of already open-source libraries
out there, like Sirocco.
And these, in some cases,
play well with each other.
So in fact, with Sirocco, I was
using the output of Cloud NLP
in order to drive Sirocco.
Or you could build
your own classifier.
You could, say,
build something that
was more focused on identifying
the subject of that emotion,
if you will.
And the point being is that
anything that you do custom,
you can then load it back into
the data transformation or ETL
system that you're
using, say, for example,
like Cloud Dataflow.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE: Can we
apply this same technique
to do Twitter analytics?
Like customers are talking
about my brand in social media
platforms like Twitter.
Can I apply the same
techniques to understand
the emotions and the sentiment
of the Twitter streams
that are coming?
ERIC SCHMIDT: Yeah, definitely.
And the path that one
would take is basically
ingesting that stream.
So Twitter is a great example.
So if you have access
to the full Firehose,
or maybe even to
the Decahose you
need to be able
to go in, ingest,
and put that data someplace
in a very low latent process.
BigQuery is a great
place to do that.
So I can basically go ahead and
read from those Twitter streams
raw, and ingest in real
time into BigQuery,
and then turn around and
write your real-time analysis
on top of it.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE:
And BigQuery
allows you to do streaming
analytics, pretty much.
Do I need to do
any configuration
to make it happen?
ERIC SCHMIDT: No.
You literally just create
a table and start writing.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE:
Wow, that's great.
And you showed Data Lab.
But if I'm an R user and I
want to use any other tool,
how do I connect to
BigQuery to analyze my data?
ERIC SCHMIDT: There are two
open source libraries right now
to connect to BigQuery.
And most recently, pandas also
just added native read support.
So now you can just go do pandas
read from Google BigQuery.
And all the underlying
connectivity, et cetera
is handled by the library.
So if you're in any type of
environment that supports
pandas, that will work nicely.
And there's also the
similar API for R.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE:
Wow, that's great.
So no need to take, like, a
data export to a separate data
store.
You just directly do it off of--
ERIC SCHMIDT: No.
If you're moving text
files around like that,
go find those libraries.
They're quite easy to use.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE: I
think the last question
we're going to take is, how do
I find more granular sentiment?
I think the question is, how
do I understand emotions?
I think you talked about
the open source library.
But can you just
re-emphasize that, please?
How do you do--
ERIC SCHMIDT: There
are other libraries
out there other than Sirocco.
But in the case of Sirocco,
the builder of it--
his name's Sergei
Sokolenko-- he's a Googler.
And he and I had several
lunches about this topic.
And it was just like he had
the existing-- or the analysis
that Plutchik built and
the research that he build
was fairly sound.
It was very well received,
and it works well
for lots of business domains.
So we whenever I was
making a decision,
I didn't necessarily
need to do more.
It provided the right
level of granularity.
What I needed was make
sure that it was accurate.
In my case, overall, it was.
So you kind of pick the
tool that you need in order
to solve the problem.
But you may find that you need
more granularity out there.
And there are other open source
libraries that you could use.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE:
OK, that's great.
And with that, we come to the
conclusion of this Cloud OnAir.
Stay tuned for the next session.
We're going to bring
GCP closer to you.
We have the next Cloud OnAir
starting from the Mountain View
office life.
So thanks for joining
Eric and myself.
And we talked about love.
Spread the word of love.
And Happy Valentine's
Day to all of you.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Take care.